all right this story is really
interesting so yesterday joe biden
called fox news reporter peter ducey a
stupid son of a [ __ ] some people say it
was a hot mic that joe biden didn't know
his mic was on it's not obvious to me i
i
when you watch the video when you listen
biden's face is right in front of a
microphone and i think it's quite
plausible biden did know that the mic
was on and it sort of like slipped out
or he just didn't care or whatever
and the incident itself is not that
interesting to me but the reaction is
absolutely fascinating because of the
incredible hypocrisy that republicans
are applying so here's the backstory
steve ducey is in the press corps for
fox news
his big thing is constantly trying to
ask gotcha questions of gensake and of
joe biden they're often very stupid but
it doesn't really matter joe biden calls
on peter ducey all the time it's known
everybody knows ducey's gonna ask
adversarial questions joe biden calls on
him all the time
he hasn't tried to get him kicked out of
the press corps he hasn't tried to get
his credential removed the way donald
trump did of jim acosta and others and
so yesterday uh as steve as peter ducey
often does he yelled a question to joe
biden the question was
is it a liability to have high inflation
and biden sort of responded no it's an
asset sarcastically and said you stupid
son of a [ __ ] so let's look here's the
video and here's the audio
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound [ __ ]
okay
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] so let's go
through this
is uh is deuce we're going to get to
glenn greenwald in a second is ducey
more or less a [ __ ] yeah his his you
know bogus gotcha questions they're just
so boring at this point
they're they're gotchas but they fail
uh now joe biden was out of line when it
comes to decorum this is not how a
president should speak to members of the
press uh i agree with the assessment of
ducey as uh basically being a [ __ ] uh
he's annoying he's just trying to get
gotchas and sound bites and whatever
but when i would criticize donald trump
and say that's not how you should be
treating members of the press
i i apply the exact same standard to joe
biden biden was out of line presidents
shouldn't speak like this even if it was
funny even if it was fun even if it was
a higher energy moment for biden
whatever okay so fine it should not have
spoken that way
that being said
there are people taking this incident
to suggest that the sky is falling and
that this is a dangerous attack on press
freedom one example is a guy named glenn
greenwald the gren glen greenwald used
to do some pretty good reporting back in
the day did a lot of interesting stuff
but now
i don't know what is going on with glenn
greenwald check out this is a very
somber greenwald reporting to us that it
is a very dark dark day in america
because of what joe biden said check
this out
hello everyone this is glenn greenwald
and today is a dark and
really dangerous day for press freedom
in america a hard-working journalist
peter ducey did nothing more than go to
work today to do his job he went to the
white house to ask a question of the
most powerful political official on the
planet president biden a question and
this is the
assault that was unleashed on him okay
so then he plays it that was it was an
assault
this is some of the fakest drama that i
can imagine here here's the bottom line
okay
biden was out of line
with peter ducey without a doubt
the people saying this was a dangerous
attack on freedom of the press that this
was an assault
when there has been no contempt for
the media from joe biden during his
presidency
these very same people i'm not talking
about greenwald now but the people look
at twitter right the very same people
losing their minds over what joe biden
said were silent during the trump
administration when trump mocked a
disabled reporter they were silent when
trump attacked jim acosta and had him
banned and when he called chuck todd a
[ __ ] and all these different things
biden was out of line
but biden called ducey to apologize
trump never apologized to the reporters
he mistreated
look at how peter ducey even describes
the conversation
after
years of clips of the president and i
kind of mixing it up on the campaign
trail and during the transition and here
at the white house
within about an hour of that exchange he
called my cell phone
and uh he said it's nothing personal pal
and we
went back and forth and we were talking
about i
just kind of
moving moving forward and i made sure to
tell him that i'm always going to try to
ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking and
he said you've got to
and that's a quote from the president
does that sound like donald trump does
that prove to us that this was a dark
and dangerous day in america
no come on guys
biden immediately apologized trump would
never apologize biden has never
advocated
for nor has he tried to ban peter ducey
from the press briefings in fact he
calls on him almost every briefing trump
took away jim acosta's press credential
joe biden has never broadly called
adversarial media
the enemy of the people he's never
called the media the enemy of the people
trump called the the enemy
referred to adversarial media as the
enemy of the people there is no
similarity between this and trump biden
was out of line i apply the same
standard to biden and trump on how they
talk to members of the media biden
apologized
and everything about the context is
completely different um give me a break
guys it's it's hard to even take
seriously
the videos like that from glenn
greenwald when what the relationship has
been with the biden administration in
the media is 180 degrees different from
what it was under trump if you disagree
with me let me know but it's uh it's
just pathetic opportunism that we are
seeing here
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 plastic free made
without any virgin tree fibers meaning
no new trees are cut down but real paper
is super soft and durable you don't have
to sacrifice quality to help the planet
these are great products from a
usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable plastic free packaging
everybody needs paper towels and toilet
paper buy ones that you will feel good
about and they're giving my audience
thirty percent off a subscription when
you go to real paper dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below